[Music]
on this friday night
clearing the air with the new travel
rules it is your responsibility to
understand and to follow all of the
rules
plus the new deal to get millions of
doses to canada
critical warnings about the variants we
are approaching the potential the third
wave
and the criticism aimed at province's
relaxing restrictions
i'm tired of filling out death
certificates delayed a surge of covet 19
postpones newfoundland and labrador's
election and we the north go south
by moving to tampa we had to change
everything the toronto raptors pandemic
playbook
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with breaking
news in newfoundland and labrador where
in-person voting has been canceled the
province is reverting to mail-in ballots
let's bring in our atlantic
correspondent ross lord who joins us
ross we know the province is now
reporting a variant of the virus and the
province reverted to the highest alert
level because of the surging cases
and now they're suspending the election
that's right they are suspending in
person voting for all
40 writings and they will not reschedule
in-person voting so i talked to the
chief electoral officer booth shock a
short time ago
it is going to sift exclusively to
voting by
mail using special ballots uh
newfoundlanders labradorians will need
to apply
uh for those special ballots by monday
february 15th
and they'll have to have their completed
voting kits back into elections
newfoundland
on or before monday march 1st
ross other provinces have managed to
pull off elections during a pandemic bc
new brunswick
did the leaders just not anticipate the
surging cases
i think that's part of the equation for
sure because you have to remember
that other than a cluster and an
outbreak last spring newfoundland has
largely stifled uh the virus and they've
had
a lot of days they've had little or no
covert 19 cases
uh the new premier called the election
to try to get a majority for his liberal
government
and then all of a sudden uh within the
past week this
outbreak explodes and according to the
chief medical officer of health in
newfoundland and labrador
uh because it is the variant first
identified in the uk
spread extremely rapidly you know these
case counts
51 day 100 yesterday
um dozens every day they
are phenomenal and it's really shaking
people there
and uh you know because of the the state
and the level and the escalation of
things right now they just said no we
can't do this we're going to
switch everything to mail-in ballot
because the province is essentially
going back
into lockdown like they were last spring
when the pandemic started
before this latest development there was
so much confusion surrounding the
different parts of the province being
able to vote in person others not being
able to quickly take us through that
yeah so plan b was
that all of the writings in saint john's
area and surrounding communities on the
avalon peninsula that's
18 ridings they would not vote
uh tomorrow which was the scheduled
election day
and they would vote at some undetermined
later date
but the other 22 writings and the rest
of the province would vote tomorrow
we had scattered reports of some cases
elsewhere today and combined with the
discovery that this variant
was the one that was first identified in
the uk
they said no we're just not going to
risk it anymore all right global
nationals ross lord on the phone with us
tonight thanks ross
the province recorded 50 new cases today
that bumps its active coven 19 case
number up to 260
the highest it has been in newfoundland
and labrador
since the pandemic began now to more
measures to prevent a third wave of
covet-19 the federal government is
promising an acceleration of vaccine
deliveries in the coming weeks
ottawa says it's now expecting 4 million
doses of the pfizer biontech vaccine
by the end of march and more than 10
million doses between april and june
the government has ordered an additional
4 million doses of the moderna vaccine
and those are expected this summer when
it comes to non-essential travel as of
february 15th
anyone arriving into canada by land will
have to provide proof of a negative pcr
test
just like arrivals by air and starting
february 22nd travelers will be required
to quarantine at a hotel
for three days at their own expense but
there's still confusion surrounding the
process
abigail beeman reports we're not trying
to punish people we're trying to keep
people
safe we now know when you'll have to pay
about two thousand dollars for a
three-day stay in a hotel upon returning
to canada by air
waiting for covet 19 test results but
there's so much we don't know
hotel booking information will be
available online
as of february 18th the requirements
come into place just four days later
you have to book specified hotels
yourself in one of the four cities where
international flights are allowed to
land
once you have a negative test you can
continue home for the rest of your
14-day quarantine
people arriving by land won't be forced
into a hotel
at land borders we have 117 different
points of entry
and many of those points of entry are
located in remote
rural areas that are not readily
accessible to
to to access to hotels as of monday
anyone entering canada by land must
also produce a negative pcr test just
like air travelers
and also new for all international
travelers as of the 22nd
two additional tests one upon arrival
another later on in quarantine because
of the variance we're going to be
testing people near the end of the
quarantine period to make sure that
it is safe for them to leave quarantine
if you are traveling
it is your responsibility to understand
and to follow all of the rules
not so easy to do when the government
itself isn't clear about them
in terms of the day 10 pcr tests they
will need to contact their local public
health authority
and arrange for testing on day 10.
while the infographic from the
minister's own department shows you will
be given a test for use on day 10
and officials say the test service
provider will pick it up from you
although they admit details are still
being worked out we have long held the
view that we needed a testing strategy
we did not think that the hotel hotel
quarantine requirement was necessary
conservatives wrote the health minister
asking for a number
of exemptions for the hotel quarantine
rules including for those traveling on
compassionate grounds
people who need non-elective medical
procedures and for family reunification
but that's something else we don't know
yet either officials say the exemptions
will be made
clear soon and only promise essential
workers
will be on that list abigail beeman
global news
ottawa ottawa is investing 53 million
dollars to ramp up efforts to detect the
new variants
across canada more than 450 confirmed
cases of these more infectious versions
of the virus have been reported in eight
provinces
the one first discovered in the uk
accounts for the majority of infections
there are 28 confirmed cases of the
variant found in south africa
and a single case of the one discovered
in brazil
and tonight bc is reporting a young
person has contracted a brand new
variant
after traveling to nigeria canada's
chief public health officer warns those
new variants threatened to derail the
work being done to cut the number of
cases and hospitalizations
at least three provinces are reporting
evidence of community spread
involving these more transmissible
variants today manitoba loosened some
restrictions gyms and restaurants can
now
open to 25 percent capacity and as
heather your quest reports
some in the medical community fear a
third wave is coming
unless we change course now a chance to
visit a restaurant or send kids back to
school
has become a welcome bit of respite for
the pandemic weary
canada appears to be coming through the
second wave
and the appetite for normalcy is strong
the combination of that
optimism from a successful lockdown
leading to
governments wanting to reopen and the
background
of these variants of concern emerging
plus delays in the vaccine arrival
is setting up really this perfect storm
for a massive third wave
ontario modeling shows that without
stronger restrictions
new variant cases will grow
exponentially in the coming weeks
to well over 1 000 daily cases by the
spring
if the b-117 variant behaves as it did
in the united kingdom
cases will start to grow here again in
late february or early march
that is unless we can limit the spread
through public health measures
and yet ontario is easing restrictions
alberta too even as the number of
variant cases in that province increases
by the day
on january 8 alberta had detected five
variant cases
just six weeks later on february 11th
there were 156
96 who did not travel we are screening
all of our positive cases
for variant strains so that we're able
to put more
intensive intervention around those
cases and really treat our variant cases
with a containment approach
but some in the medical community
believe the opportunity to contain these
new variants has
passed modeling out of the university of
calgary suggests that the variant first
discovered in the uk
could be the dominant strain in alberta
by march given the doubling time of the
cases of the new variant that we've seen
in alberta over recent weeks i do
believe that we are
approaching the potential of a third
wave if we don't take further
action now a difficult decision left
once again
in the hands of provincial leaders
nearly a year after the first
calls to lock down the threat of covet
19
is far from done heather urex west
global news
calgary there's a scramble around the
world to secure enough vaccine but
federal regulators in the u.s have a
plan
a potential quick fix to boost supply
according to the new york times the u.s
food and drug administration says
moderna can put 40
more vaccine into each of its files that
works out to 14 doses in each vial
as opposed to 10 increasing america's
vaccine supply by 20 percent
the fda is asking the drug maker to
provide data to make sure it doesn't
compromise the quality of the vaccine
health canada says it's aware of the fda
report
it says it has not yet received an
application for moderna
to make the change for this country
turning to washington now in the
impeachment trial
donald trump's legal team wrapped up its
much anticipated defense for three hours
trump's lawyers argued he did not incite
the january sixth capital riots and that
his words were just figures of speech
they called the case against the former
president a political witch-hunt
and as jackson proskow reports it didn't
end there
an unjust and blatantly unconstitutional
act of political vengeance in
trump-style language
you get more due process than this when
you fight a parking ticket
the former president's defense team
argued he did nothing to incite the mob
that stormed the capitol
clearly there was no insurrection they
made accusations of doctored evidence
and false claims about who was behind
the violence
one of the first people arrested was the
leader of antifa
they tried to equate trump's speech to
the summer protests against racial
injustice
and the words used by democrats winning
the fight
fight fighting he's fighting no human
being seriously
believes that the use of such
metaphorical terminology
is incitement to political violence
notably there was little mention of
trump's months of lies about a stolen
election
or of trump's calls to his supporters to
be in washington on january
6th or an explanation of why trump
waited so long to tell the mob to leave
the capitol building
this appalling abuse of the constitution
only further divides our nation when we
should be trying to come together
despite a likely acquittal there were
signs of republicans who might break
ranks
exactly when did president trump learn
of the breach of the capitol
what specific actions did he take to
bring
the writing to an end that question from
two republican senators was met with no
answer from trump's defense
with the rush to bring this impeachment
there's been absolutely no
investigation into that knowing that an
acquittal is still the most likely
outcome senators are moving quickly to
wrap up the trial
there's still no expectation that
witnesses will be called and a final
vote could come as early as saturday
afternoon
robin jackson prosco in washington
the new hurdle ahead of the tokyo
olympics coming up why the chief of the
games
quit plus bringing in the lunar new year
in the time of kovid
[Music]
every day more cases of the new more
contagious variants of kova 19 are being
confirmed in canada
the one first detected in the uk seems
to be spreading the fastest
and since the variants are easier to
catch canadians are likely going to have
to brace themselves for
even tighter public health restrictions
in the weeks to come
donna friesen is taking a deeper look in
this week's edition
of the new reality donna robin a key
question is whether we've learned enough
from what happened last spring
we know the virus thrives when we move
around it needs human hosts to spread
and mutate
that's what's propelled the coronavirus
to spread from china all over the world
these new variants are testing us again
they are spreading faster than the
vaccines are rolling out
yet there is no consensus about how to
restrict
how we move around we're looking at
really every measure that's been
implemented by every country i spoke
with professor
kelly lee at bc's simon fraser
university she's part of an
international group
analyzing travel restrictions how do you
think
the conversation the thinking the
strategy about
travel restrictions has evolved from the
beginning to where we are
now so at the beginning way back in
january february the received wisdom
really was that travel related
restrictions don't work
and who put out the recommendation that
countries should not adopt such measures
as this pandemic has unfolded we've seen
that
actually there are some situations where
actually it can work
it's worked in australia and new zealand
where life is largely back to normal
because of tight border controls and
strict lockdowns when
even a single case emerges that's one
part of our story
tomorrow we'll also explain how labs in
this country are hunting for the
variants
why genomic sequencing is so critical
and whether
enough is being done plus the
uncertainty about whether variants can
re-infect those who have already
recovered
from covid19 robin all right good stuff
donna
to watch donna's full story tune into
the new reality tomorrow night
right here on global the world needs
more canada
that was then how about now still ahead
canada's role
on the world stage
five years ago prime minister justin
trudeau declared canada's back on the
international stage
the liberal government was signaling it
wanted to build a stronger relationship
with world organizations
like nato and get back into the business
of peacekeeping
so did canada follow through michael
couture has a reality check
last year's loss of the united nations
security council seat was seen as a blow
to canada's brand on the world
stage but perhaps it was also a wake-up
call
for the need to reframe where we see
ourselves in the post-covid19 world
canada's foreign policy is a bit
undeclared bessma momani teaches
political science at the university of
waterloo
while she applauds the liberals focus on
a feminist foreign policy
she wonders how effective it will be if
you're looking for a policy that you can
achieve your goals with very little
financial resources to it that is not
one that you should put your monies
you know into because it is a it is an
expensive endeavor and you're going to
face a lot of global resistance to it
the feminist foreign policy is aimed at
helping women and girls around the world
with an emphasis
on female entrepreneurs but our
international aid budget is only about
6 billion a year or 0.27 percent of
gross domestic
income far below the traditional goal of
0.7 percent
of gdi the world needs more
canada that famous phrase delivered by
former u.s president barack obama was a
call for canada
to get more involved but some believe we
haven't stepped up
we're not really in a in a clear lane
former canadian diplomat randolph bank
led
canada's last major foreign policy
review in 2003.
he believes the trudeau government needs
to address the security of our cyber
dependents
that can only be done through deterrence
and
new international treaties around arms
control the weaponization of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
things like that that we're not caught
up on internationally at all
that was a 2019 liberal campaign promise
but there's little
evidence of progress the establishment
of the canadian center for peace order
and good government was another promise
without action but this former diplomat
believes
it could build on our strengths i would
point to
participation in the group that's trying
to bring democracy to venezuela
and our efforts through the ottawa group
to reform the world
trade organization to bring the united
states back into it a type of peace
brokering that was once a hallmark of
canada
and one that is all the more important
as world powers like china and russia
move away from multilateralism michael
couture global news ottawa
the head of tokyo's olympic organizing
committee resigned today after sparking
a wave of international criticism by
suggesting
women talk too much in meetings yashira
mori's resignation comes with just over
five months to go until the summer games
his exit could further complicate japan
hosting the olympics which had to be
delayed until this year because of the
pandemic
a selection committee now has to be
formed to choose a new president
up next basketball in the ballroom how
the toronto raptors are keeping a
practice
during a pandemic
tennis fans booed while being let out of
the arena where the australian open is
being played
the tournament will continue without
crowds for five days
the state of victoria entered a snap
lockdown to contain a new outbreak of
coven 19.
it's been linked to a quarantine hotel
in melbourne the highly contagious
variant first found in the uk
is among the cluster of cases the virus
has forced canada's
only nba team to play out its season in
the u.s
the toronto raptors have relocated to
tampa florida because of complications
crossing the border
our mike armstrong was in tampa for
another story but wanted to drop in on
the raptors to see how the move has gone
it didn't quite turn out the way he'd
hoped there is
an irony in a team branding itself we
the north
having to move to the u.s south
there's also an irony that to cover that
move
even though we were in tampa we had to
do our interviews with team officials
by zoom the covet 19 safety protocols
are that tight
by moving to tampa we had to change
everything teresa resh is the vice
president of basketball operations
and a big part of the team that moved
the raptors to tampa's amelie arena for
games
and a hotel next door for practices
[Music]
they turned the ballroom at a jw
marriott into a complete practice
facility
and team headquarters under a deadline
resh still has trouble believing
we moved an entire organization in two
weeks you know we've we've spent 25
years building up what the toronto
raptors are in toronto and to just pick
that up and move it to a completely
different country in two weeks
it was everything yeah i like it yeah
they really
really put their time now to make the
move the raptors turned to a canadian
company
bam productions it had to build
everything from scratch
in a hotel that itself was literally
still under construction
it hadn't even opened we just needed
everything
out of the way they were installing
lights and we needed them to be taken
down
as they were bringing things in we
needed to take to have them take it out
now there's also another irony the team
was moved to tampa because of the
pandemic
that meant moving employees with the
raptors and bam
from ontario to florida a place where
there's actually more kovid 19
and it spreading faster the employees
were allowed to choose whether to go
or not those are individual decisions
and
so not everybody that was invited is
here and
that's okay we'll hope that we can get
them the next time the
other people who aren't here are the
fans florida is allowing spectators at
sporting events
the super bowl in tampa had 22 000 fans
in attendance last weekend this marks
the first time
fans are in the in miami the heater now
playing in front of sparse crowds
fans have to walk past coveted sniffing
dogs to get in
the owner of the arena where the raptors
are playing hopes to reopen to fans
at least a few thousand at a time later
this month
mike armstrong global news tampa and
that is global national for this friday
night
i'm robin gill we leave you tonight with
a roaring start
to the lunar new year
bc's kung fu club posted this
traditional lion dance
lion dances are said to bring prosperity
and good luck
which we could all certainly use this
year
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you